[Applause]
of
course the big thing that's most
exciting is we have the Super Bowl set
it is the Kansas City Chiefs against the
San Francisco
49ers okay
and interesting wrinkle first year just
Las Vegas first year we're doing that in
Las Vegas it's going to be a little
different uh prostitutes are
um are offering the Travis Kelsey
special it's
uh for for an for an extra 50 you can
score in their tight end it's uh I know
it's
[Applause]
terrible but here's the great story of
the week and it's about the Super Bowl
and it just shows I mean the right-wing
they are just mental like I can't
even they have a conspiracy theory
now that this whole game the whole thing
is real
okay that the romance between tlor Swift
and Travis Kelce was engineered by the
Pentagon a psycho op operation psych
psycho op is exactly what it is scop
Operation uh and the NFL is in on it the
whole season is rigged so that they
could be in the Super Bowl and then at
the Super Bowl Travis Kelce and Taylor
Swift at halftime will endorse
Biden
well all I have to say about this is
abort they're on to
us you know really that's what it is
that this whole romance was engineered
to throw an
election or maybe just the popular girl
is dating the football player you
know
uh and look I think Taylor Swift is
great all respect for what she's
achieved but this is so high school is
it not I mean
just my boyfriend's a football player
and I wear his jacket with his number to
the game
and he's going to be prom King and we're
going to make fetch happen again I mean
okay but but it has driven
them it has driven the rightwing CR I
mean Fox News they have it outdone
themselves I Fox News these guys amaz
everything with them is always a plot
it's it's always a it's always a
conspiracy yeah except the time people
actually stormed the
capital on the very day they were
certifying the votes that was just
spontaneous
fun but this thing they are worked up
about this like I can't tell you I mean
they even think that they can criticized
they're doing this on Fox News uh Tor
Swift for flying on a private jet
because it's bad for the
the CO2 that's how irrational Taylor
Swift has these people they're worrying
about climate change and rooting for San
Francisco